AND THE WINNIPEG JETS GET THE
OPENING GOAL.IS IS ONE THAT KOS
LIKE TO HAVE
GET TO IT AND HOLD IT OUT AS
KYLE CONNOR WAS BANGING AWAY AT
IT
BEHIND
THE EDEDESSE PULJUJARVI WAS
IN LOOKING FOR A REBOUND
>> KevininSCHEIFELE
YAMAMOTO THE FIRST ON THE PUCK.
TO THE JETS 7, STANLEY
WITH 6:22.
ON THE TO McDAVID, SAVE, REBOUN
SAVE!URSE -- OR PARDON
ME, DRAISAITL.
THERE'S THE FIRST FOR MORRISSEY
SCHMIDT, AND HE KNUCKLED IT
COPP.
>> Ryan: GOT TIED UP BY SECOND .
THREE POWER PLAY GOALS ON THE
YEAR OUT BY KEITH,
KEITH CHASES THAT. BATTLE DOWN .
NICE JOB KEEPING IT GOING.
DUNCAN KEITH POPS THE PUCK.
THRE
BACONOT IS ON NET, PULJUJARVI I
THERE, IF IT
[ Horn ].
[ Cheers and Applause ]
>> DY BUT WHEN YOU PIECE
BACKHANDER WIDE, AND SCHEIFELE
WILL SEND IT OFF FBOUCHARD.HE
GOAL LINE, TRYING TO CENTRE IT
IS HYMAN AND TH
AFTER PUSH, AND THERE IT IS, THE
SELL JOB, AS THE HEADEEN DOWN T.
McDAVID CROSS ICE, HERE.
THIS GAME COULD GET AN EXTRA
BOOST OF ENERGY.
HERE IS THE OFF.
HELLEBUYCK, NO
>> Kevin: HE'S SAYING PULJUJARVI
WAS PUSHED INTO HIM.
IMPORTANT PART OF THE GAME HERE
THEIR DECISION.
AND HERE COMES THE CALL.
TOUGHEST PART FOR THE JETS SO
WILL TAKE IT AWAY.
THE BLOCK AND THE CLEAR, GOOD ON
THE SFLIEN OVER A MINUTE AND A
HALF. LOOK AT THE
TENACIOUSNESS OFF THE HIP OF
DRAISAITL.